all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the conclusion
of siege
i.e the death of loki and this was
cool because this is like the first real
time in marvel comics when like loki
really and truly died right it was it
was nuts lucky in his current form
gone right done so it's it's basically
it i mean i guess it was kind of loki
coming back to a degree in the aftermath
of ragnarok but like his spirit lived on
right like in this instance loki as you
know him like the god of tricksters and
lies and so on so forth he's gone right
it's it's
that's it and the loki that you get is
like a totally different version of its
character so
in the last video we had essentially
discussed how we ended up having the
events of siege which was based on the
idea that norman osborne as the director
of shield
sought to take out asgard itself and was
really handed asgard
by loki the motivation of loki doing
this was not doing it for the sake of
destroying asgard that was not really
his intention the idea of loki is that
asgard does not belong among the human
race mostly because
humans are just too primitive right that
asgard is the home of gods
and therefore it deserves a realm unto
itself what loki did not account for was
norman osborne taking this conflict to
such an extreme degree and then in turn
it leading to the seeming total
destruction of asgard
at the hands of the century and the void
and so that's one of the things that
loki regrets right loki says okay
like this is my mistake here like it's
one of the he kind of opens up with this
idea of like father believe me i did not
mean to bring this fight to your
doorstep
in this capacity i didn't think this
would happen and this is one of those
instances
when loki underestimated the power of
the void right the voyage the alter ego
of the century he's the evil persona of
century all his fear and security but
this guy
is on a whole nother level of power
luckily for loki
he has in his possession the nornstones
now let's talk about the nornstones for
a second because a lot of you guys know
these exist
and the nornstones can be a little bit
murky so one of the things that goes on
here is that they're used by loki to
basically
empower or to offer a kind of second
wind and enhance the abilities
of the avengers themselves so they can
actually win against the void
otherwise that would never happen so the
nornstones do not possess
a definitive power source which is to
say they don't guarantee you a certain
kind of power so it's not as though if
you have the nornstones then you can
alter reality on a cosmic scale
the power you get from the norns is
contingent on the person who wields them
and whether or not the norns will
satisfy their desires in this
instance loki wants to empower the
avengers so they can defeat the void
if the nornstones didn't want that to
happen they wouldn't allow it to happen
right it's one of those things that kind
of goes into the character of carnila
and they're a little bit you know
interesting and kind of wonky in terms
of how they work that's one of the
things about them marvel plays it fast
and loose with how these things work
they don't really give us definitive
answers and so that's one of the things
that kind of goes on that's why the
avengers are able to fight any capacity
that they are
is because the northern stones are used
by loki the avengers are all able to
fight in a more unified function
and their powers are bolstered this is
necessary because defeating the void is
not an easy thing
we covered that when we did the story
with uh with the launch of new avengers
by brian michael bendis
when the void was taking on the combined
forces of all the x-men
the fantastic four and all the avengers
at the same time
and it was all they could do to live
right i mean it's just it's insane how
much power this guy has
and so with all of them fighting
together the void starts to pick up on
the fact that something's different and
he notices it coming from thor
right his idea is like okay your energy
signature is not what it was before your
powers like you have new abilities that
you didn't have before
something's going on here this is some
kind of a trick it's gotta be mischief
and that's when he seeks out loki now of
course
thor tries to get there in time but
ultimately it doesn't work and in
probably one of the most significant
moments for
loki's character in the history of
marvel comics like when the as as like
the void
is setting on loki loki just looks at
thor and says i'm sorry brother
and that's the end of him right like
like loki is just totally incinerated by
the void and loki officially dies let me
tell you something the time this story
came out when that happened
it was huge people were like whoa
like the void just killed loki like holy
cow like
marvel killed loki off it was kind of
nuts right it was it was
bonkers when that happened well all
that's going on norman osborne's getting
while the getting's good right you know
the funny thing he immediately bumps
into captain america
captain america is like no no no that's
not going to happen you know and
ultimately like he asked him like how do
we control this guy right how do we get
the void back out of this and how do we
get robert reynolds back again and the
response of norman is no you don't
understand he's the angel of death
right like there's no there's no undoing
this right like there's no
putting the cat back in the bag and so
ultimately you have iron man right tony
stark who comes to the rescue on this
now here's the thing man
tony stark right as much as he's a dick
he's got it where it
counts man the important thing is iron
man's like okay so he gets up he gets a
hold of the helicarrier and he's like is
there anybody left on there and he
didn't have a force victoria hand who's
like yeah i mean we're here we're
evacuating everybody and he's like okay
fine you got 10 seconds to get off the
ship and they're like why he's like i'm
crashing this thing
so literally that's exactly what he does
right like he basically uses this
technology
to take over the uh the ship itself and
then crashes it into the void right like
just crashes the scene directly in him
nowhere
near enough energy to kill him right
that's not the case at all it's not
enough to kill him
but it's certainly enough to basically
incapacitate him and to force him back
into robert reynolds and when robert
reynolds shows back up again
it's like okay like what in the world
that's one of the things to keep in mind
robert reynolds like
it's almost like the incredible hulk
kind of thing right like there's a
there's almost a point
when robert just can't stop himself from
turning into the void and when that
happens
all hell bracelets not only that it's a
curse for him right because you're
talking about a being of insurmountable
power the void being defeated is
temporary
robert reynolds is holding him in as
best he can and he asks iron man like
will you please
kill me like please for the love of god
kill me and thor says no
and he's like but please do this and
thor's response is no you're gonna have
to stand for your crimes right
you will live to see penance for the
death of my brother for the fall of my
entire home i'm not going to let you off
by killing you and then in terms like
you're not listening to me
i can't keep them contained and the void
re-emerges right
like pops back out yet again and so
ultimately thor just uses all the might
that he possibly has everything he can
muster
and just calls down the thunder on the
void using his mystical energy and
basically incinerates the body of robert
reynolds robert reynolds is
dead the century's been killed like
literally and the way we knew that
happened
is because like the century citadel
basically fades from existence it
disappears
and then in turn thor is like nope we
got to make sure this guy stays dead so
he wraps him in his cape
flies him into space and drops him in
the sun and leaves him there right and
this is like he's totally
he's gone right body's incinerated the
whole nine yards now to a degree it was
kind of giving a bit of a funeral i mean
there's not a lot of love loss here
right i mean the guy killed his brother
but basically the whole thing's said and
done right i mean everybody who was here
the ufos
all the the people who were part of
norman osborne's brigade norman osborne
himself is captured by captain america
like the day is basically over right
it's all essentially said and done and
so what you end up getting is kind of
this amazing little aftermath
this is really what leads into like
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers with regards to captain america
being director of shield the reality
is that following everything that had
gone on steve rogers kind of chastises
them to a degree not officially not
unlike you guys are idiots but i mean
come on right like they had tony stark
as director of shield in the aftermath
of civil war
given the kind of things he was doing i
mean they put in norman osborn the green
goblin
as director of shield and then he
disbanded it and turned it into hammer
and so captain america kind of has to be
there like you guys are kind of idiots
because they're asking him to be the one
to step up
and kind of lead things now now the the
for the government's part it should have
always been steve rogers who played that
role right it should have always kind of
been him there and that's one of the
things that goes on right it's kind of
like look you know we're starting to see
the world the way that nick fury sought
right according to nick fury we've been
seeing the world the way tony stark
saw it we saw the world that way norman
osborne saw it and each one of these
guys had massive problems but captain
america your values what you stand for
what's important to you
that's beyond contestation no one
questions you the superhero community
respects you entirely your whole your
whole stance during
civil war was predicated on the idea of
putting freedom first
even if humanity uses that freedom to
try to destroy itself it was still
something that you advocated and so
ultimately it's kind of like we want you
to be the guy who basically runs or kind
of operates as the federal liaison to
what is essentially the avengers right
we want you to run this whole thing and
so this was exceedingly important
because this led to a couple different
situations the first thing is
this officially saw the ending of
superhuman registration right so the
aftermath of civil war
is done there's no more secret avengers
anymore there's no more underground
avengers teams or anything like that
it basically concludes all that stuff
the next thing is
a new avengers team is being formed and
that's really one of the big things that
comes in the aftermath of siege and the
heroic age
is the launch of a new avengers title
and a new avengers roster so that was a
cool thing that goes on there and
the the last thing this really did is
kind of talking about heroic age this
basically ushered in
kind of coming out of the dark rain era
and ushered in a kind of era of peace or
at least that's what you hoped for
then we got the incursions and
everything started falling apart
but in essence asgard kind of goes back
to being asgard you do see some cool
things where you see like iron man
rebuilding a new asgard for for all the
asgardians there technically it's called
asgardia or at least it ends up becoming
that at a future point in time but the
new avengers roster is kind of a
combination
of the new avengers as we know them
combined with the mighty avengers right
steve rogers goes back to being captain
america after taking the mantle away
from bucky barnes because during this
time this was bucky barnes as captain
america right this was bucky barnes when
he was operating
after steve rogers had died or at least
believed to have been killed steve
rogers came back but bucky was the one
who maintained
the role right maintain the captain
america position eventually steve rogers
gets it back the mighty avengers all
that stuff
this all comes out of it like the ending
of siege was a huge paradigm shift for
marvel so if you guys are interested in
seeing everything that comes after siege
the mighty avengers and all that kind of
stuff let me know because it's
really really really really cool but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace